Kris Jenner parties in San Tropez as Rob
Kardashian faces a legal battle back
home with ex blac Chyna I personally on
mr. Kardashian's behalf apologized and
offered our regrets for what has taken
place in the past couple of days the
famous momager and her boyfriend Cory
gamble were spotted in San Tropez
enjoying a romantic tropical getaway
just days after her son was involved in
an explicit social media rampage against
ex-fiance blac Chyna like what the 61
year old was even photographed doing a
little shopping in France on Monday back
home a judge granted Chyna
a temporary restraining order against
Rob which restricts him from posting
about her on social media I would like
to first and foremost thank the judge
for granting me this restraining order
to protect me and I'm just gonna get
back to co-parenting dreams the model
broke her silence during an interview
with ABC News Monday revealing that she
returns to luxury cars and her
engagement ring to rob after he posted
sexually explicit images of her on
social media and reportedly boasted
about spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars on her I was devastated of
course I'm like how could somebody like
post these pictures of me and I'm like
like whoa okay like this is a person and
I trust it despite the drama in Los
Angeles Chris seems to be making the
most of her time away from the states
and is now with her man in Italy
[Music]